hey show these garbage people out take
the garbage out Eddie
Donna gentlemen I've been auditing the
budget and I noticed you're way behind
in your paperwork
Jerry haven't filled out a pc10 form in
two and a half years geez I'm sorry yeah
we kind of do our paperwork at our own
speed oh really
well I kind of need you to do it at my
speed fine I'll do them what is wrong
with you today did they cancel Game of
Thrones
nothing is wrong just do your job and
they could never cancel Game of Thrones
it's a crossover hit it's not just for
fantasy enthusiasts they're telling
human stories in a fantasy world
eleven Oh Lord is he eating soup on a
bench alone Tom fine my rubber band come
with us what no arguing no soup events
what what is happening right now
blood lake
now I missed the first three death canoe
films why exactly is it a defconn it is
a tip over easily read my Twitter feed I
live-tweeted the first three this
morning in preparation in the fifth one
the canoes actually the hero
it's crazy twist son I'm just saying you
should have put spoiler alert on all
those death canoe tweets also
not-safe-for-work
you know a lot of what you wrote was
really profane the movie is 25 years old
Morris and if you don't like how I tweet
don't follow me
what are you doing now I'm talking to
you I'm live tweeting this dumbass
conversation Ben don't you dare hurt her
I won't don't laugh she means it yeah I
I won't seriously son don't hurt her
okay I'm not planning on hurting her you
better not be I'm not hey Ben you best
watch yourself why would any of you
think I would hurt Leslie you're all my
friends to know this was literally the
most beautiful and moving thing that I
have ever there there baby boy hey
whatever happened to you and the bionic
man Chris he broke up with me but he did
it so nicely that I didn't even realize
he did it I've done that to multiple men
how you doing you don't okay thank you
so much for asking it's been tough
yeah two days ago I was sobbing at a
pizza buffet and they asked me to leave
I've been looking at some dog adoption
websites about $700 with the candles
from Anthropologie I did this to my hair
your basic bottoming out kind of stuff
yeah normally people tell you talk about
your problems I'm gonna recommend you
bottle that noise up that's what my
mailman said hmm ya feel Oh what are you
doing tonight I think I'm gonna have to
pass your loss are you gonna get him
he's an exactly boyfriend material
who said anything about a boyfriend use
him abuse him lose him ladies choice Oh
wildcard option okay anybody reveal
anything about their life anything at
all I've gotten two annulment one for
pleasure and one to cap off a long con I
was running against Keith Sweat Wow
let's talk about personal relationships
who wants to start Donna I have several
men of rotation ones waiting for me out
in the car don't worry I wrote down the
window now we are going to build a
better water fountain for the parks Andy
is our official water fountain tester
all right let's give this sucker a
test-drive yeah so the idea is to make a
fountain that he can't do that to that's
good okay any ideas Jerry well I was
thinking that we could put this cage
thing around it okay that could work
Andy
thank you Andy
still good top full disclosure Ann and I
are romantically intertwined God so
let's not be surprised if you fix my
idea would you just go dummy what's the
best kind of water fountain how about no
water fountain this is the Voss water
Butler bye to me at only $600 about
April what's your idea to go in that
room and finish this book really yeah is
it good yeah I'm gonna stay here and
you're gonna help don't don't look like
I drink water
Donna oh my god I am so excited to see
you here these things are horrible when
you're by yourself what do you know
where you are right now we're in the
jungle
there are no friends here it's every
woman for herself you're joking right
I look like I'm joking dating is a
zero-sum game if you get a man I don't
get that man I'm here because of advice
that you gave me to be more adventurous
in my life here's some more advice beat
it hi I'm Anne Bryan what's your
occupation I'm a manager at a sporting
goods store no way me too seriously
which one no I'm not Am I
I was just ribbing here what are you
drinking
yeah what oh I don't know I couldn't
hear you
so you just laughed and said yeah yeah
excuse us
that was the worst thing I've ever seen
in my life did you up in the woods or
you know from the movie milk I told you
I'm rusty all right come with me you
always want to scribble the name make
them read draw them in make them work
for it great two shots of Jameson don't
make too much eye contact you want to
see them available but not two of it
Thanks I think I'm good for now I'm not
gonna yeah all right let's do this
that went better right yes did however
proudly tell me that he beat herpes I'm
sorry - I'm gonna go home I just found
out Andy's getting married so so that's
my ex-boyfriend we were together for a
really long time all right what what
listen you are a hot young doctor I'm a
nurse actually okay I don't know you but
I do know that you can fix your attitude
do you want to go home and feel sorry
for yourself about a man you didn't want
to marry or do you want to go talk to
that cute boy who has been looking at
you and give him your number before I
throw him in my bands for myself all
right all right safety basics Donna tell
me why it's bad to look down the barrel
of your gun is that a trick question no
Donna don't please rule number one do
not point the weapon at a person that
includes your own face Donna your
favorite kind of cake can't be birthday
cake that's like saying your favorite
card see Rose breakfast here hello
breakfast cereal I was shot in the head
with a shotgun it's actually not that
serious I just need you to stay calm
okay yeah I'm just gonna stay angry I
find that relaxes me okay Romi call
9-1-1 and they're gonna send a ranger oh
damn this is a mess the Rangers won't
let us come back next year we're not
gonna think about that right now you
guys can you just put him on the daybed
in the car Dave yeah
[Applause]
[Applause]
what is it your heart you should listen
to him those books are good oh I love
any book about vampires werewolves
monsters zombies sorcerers beasties or
time-traveling romances and if I had an
hour alone with Robert Pattinson he
would forget all about skinnylegs mcgee
I tell you that much
pubic hairs get longer the older you got
I don't think so no because that's
happening to me what should I do
where can I get Lube that is healthy to
eat look we can dance all day but it's
time to step up
are you buying 4,000 rubber nipples for
me or nuts
dee you have a visitor we back we're
back oh listen I heard about the
accident and I need to know who is
responsible
I shot Ron Swanson
you